You're not welcome. Why don't Why don't
we Why don't we talk about it? With your
misogyny, with your violence. What
violence? What do you do with what
violence? You can't You can't leave
Islam and you you
What happened to Edward Snowden? What
happened to Edward Snowden? Excuse me.
I'm speaking. Oh. Oh. Oh, sorry, master.
I'm sorry, master. I'm I'm I'm listening
you. Sorry, master. You're the one who
actually exercised modern day.
Assalamu alaykum. I really want to thank
Walk forever for partnering with
Abdullah in this absolutely amazing very
very important project of providing
prosthetic limbs to those thousands
who've lost their limbs in Gaza. They
are telling us that this is the best
gift you could have given us. Restoring
the mobility is like restoring their
lives. That's what they're saying. So,
subhan Allah, people have lost both
limbs. People have lost hands and uh
legs. uh some above the knee, some below
the knee. Mashallah, this is just one
example
Ahmed. Mashallah, he's one of the so
many whom we've been able to assist with
your partnership. So, may Allah reward
you and grant you goodness and may Allah
almighty continue to use all of us to do
this good work.
[Music]
in a sexual manner. So, Islam has taught
me to treat women as a human being, not
as a sexual object. So, the western
world has done the opposite with the
pornography, with um having chocolate
bars and a half naked woman next to I
don't know what the chocolate bars got
to do with a woman. So, because sex
cells, they have uh used that and
they've dehumanized women and that's
come at the cost of their mental
well-being being affected. So I think in
Islam they find uh liberty, they find
freedom, true freedom and I think that's
why we have a lot of women uh who accept
Islam and I think that's a main factor
as well and there's books written on it
on this matter. It's called one there's
a book called beauty sick. So it talks
about the sickness of beauty among young
girls specifically you know starving the
self to have the perfect body and what
is the perfect body? My daughter's 19.
She's very skinny and she's fat. But
well, exactly. And do you see do you see
do you see those pressures? But in the
book it was it was telling it was I was
reading it. It's quite a non saying
she's non-Muslim woman. She was talking
about how girls are they have so much
pressure on them. They were saying I
wish I did not have to think about how I
look so I can spend more quality time
with my friends and my family. Just be
yourself. But you can't because you got
so many standards. You got your friends.
You got peer pressure. So what the hijab
does, hijab is the hijab is a symbol to
to distinguish obviously okay that's a
Muslim woman but also at the same time
when I'm speaking to um an individual
I'm speaking to them rather than
speaking to something else and as men we
are u you know distracted by yes that's
that's that's how that's that's how
we're created. So as men we have that
innate desire towards towards a woman.
So what God Almighty does is that's why
he tells us tell the believing men to
lower your gaze. So first it teaches men
how to be how to behave towards women.
So there is no like oh men can't control
the so you have to cover up. It does
that's a big misconception that's not
true in Islam. A man is told on a micro
level to a macro level how to behave and
how to treat the opposite gender and
then the woman does a job. So they work
both simultaneously you know cuz at the
end of the day you know um it's not just
a matter of like people come and say oh
is it to protect me from rape. No cuz
women in hijab get raped. So that's not
the factor. Even even though like for
example it goes back to like cat calling
being sexually harassed 90% of women in
the western world have either been
sexually harassed or been catc calledled
so they can't walk in peace. So and not
only that as as a man as a as a man
myself uh I I was I came to Islam 12 13
years ago. So before that I was not a
Muslim even though I look Muslim. So um
I used to come and club and party in
this very strip every every weekend. It
was pointless. It was boring. It was the
same old thing. uh you know and I I
realized you know um men tend to fall in
love the wrong way as men we can fall in
love the wrong way and I wouldn't call
it love but I would call it lust but
what happens is uh when a woman is
dressed in an appropriate way obviously
man is he he has those desires to be
with her so then he gives a false
promises he's not serious with her so
what the hijab does the hijab says okay
you know cover your adornments your
beauty and the man should obviously um
lower his gaze if the woman does his job
and then if I'm interested I go about
the right the right way like for example
when I met my wife. I had to speak to
her father. We don't we don't believe in
dating. We don't believe in because we
believe men can take advantage of that.
You know, I could I can just abuse a
woman and give her promises. And not
only that, you have a daughter. How old
is she? 19. She's 19. I mean, you like
she said, oh, I have a boyfriend. I
mean, you would be a bit concerned
about, okay, who is he? Cuz she's she's
a girl. What's his name? What's his
name? Yes. I want to I want to meet him.
What does he do for work? Exactly. And
the reason why you have that concern is
because you're a mother and your your
your husband would be far more um
concerned because he's a man. So um in
Islam, Islam says there is no dating uh
outside of marriage. Uh this doesn't
mean you can't get to know one another.
You can. It's done with a chaperon.
Okay. Yeah. So like for example, when I
was getting to know my wife marriage,
her sister, her dad would either allow
her sister or her brother to be there.
So if we're going to a restaurant, it's
not going to sit on the same table.
It'll just be there. If we're walking,
it's just a bit behind us. And the
reason being is because Islam deals with
the reality. It's pragmatic. It deals
with the reality of the world. It
doesn't live in Laland. Islam Islam is
incompatible with Western Christian
democracy. Christian you really this
Quran. You're not welcome. Why don't why
don't why don't we talk about it? With
your misogyny, with your violence. What
violence? With what you do with what
violence? You can't you can't leave
Islam and you you you
What happened to Edward Snowden? What
happened to Edward Snowden? Excuse me.
I'm speaking. Oh, sorry, master. I'm
sorry, master. I'm I'm I'm listening.
I'm sorry, master. You're the ones who
are actually exercising modern day.
Please, my friend, my friend, you're an
ignorant person. We actually come
educate yourself. You abolish slavery.
Typical typical Islamist. You have to
talk over. I won't talk. You talk. We
abolish slavery in this in this country
and in the world. You you Islamists cuz
I lived in the Middle East in Dubai and
Abu Dhabi. Wait, wait, wait. You
actually exercise and still employ
modern day slavery. You burn and you
murder apostates from from Islam. I
think you're watching I think you're
watching too much. Oh, there you go.
There you go. I'm I'm going to I'm going
to talk I'm going to talk and walk off.
It's it's it's as you can see and you
can see the difference between somebody
who wants to learn and then you got
someone who's ignorant. He's not opening
his head. Yeah, of course he is. Of
course. That's why I knew he's not going
to let me speak. He just wants to
express himself. He's frustrated and I
don't blame him. He watches too much
horror movies. He's a bit confident
having that much to say while you're
wearing clothes. Exactly. Exactly. So to
me, look, I don't have mind having a
conversation, but I know he just wanted
to talk and walk. He just wanted to be
abusive. Exactly. Exactly. And that's
why like this that's that's why there
lovely people like you and that's why I
don't judge people you know he's talking
about you like as if because you you
don't know nothing about me you know but
anyways exactly I'm violent and I yeah
the fact that you were able to take that
and not allow it to penetrate you cuz
you know what we deal with out of
respect we can't touch obvious gender
but but but we can do a a in the air
yeah I'll come I'll come to that as well
so the thing is it's it's like um I
don't have mind having a dialogue you
can come here and say, "You know what? I
want to know why do this? Let's have a
talk. Let's discussion." But you come
here, you're evil, you're murderer,
you're killer, you're okay, that's
that's that's sad. But anyway, exactly
the sort of person that your colleague
was talking to me about. Was he okay? I
don't even know. Okay. Yeah. Is the
stigmatization stereotype, you know, and
and and and the thing is they don't even
want to educate the ignorance. If he
came and said, you know what, look, I've
got some misconceptions. Do you guys do
this and this? Okay, let's talk about
it. That's what you saw. Even when I
went to speak, he has this inferiority
complex. I'm the law. He's the and he's
like a master. Something that I've
always been very mindful of is that when
there is an act of terrorism,
um who did it? Yeah. Because it's like
your colleague was saying that guy that
drove I think it was ex Navy or
something. The um Liverpool, he drove
into the crowd. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. He was a white man. They
don't care. So what? That's all right
then, is it? Exactly. So it's it's the
the thing is it's because the hatred
that was a
Muslim. That would be an act of
terrorism. And not only that, when that
happened, the far right jumped on and
said, "It's a Muslim. It's a Muslim."
And the moment they find it, they're
like, "Oh, it's one of ours. It's fine.
He can run us over. It's just as long as
the Muslim doesn't run us over, we're
cool with our own." It's it's crazy. And
doesn't Allah not He doesn't like people
getting hurt. No, of course not. To us,
Allah does hurt. There is a verse in the
Quran, and the Quran only has this
verse. It says if you kill one soul as
if you killed the whole of humanity and
if you save one soul it's as if you save
the whole of humanity. In Islam
categorically to kill innocent people is
forbidden. That's why when you look at
what's happened in Israel in their
scripture he actually tells them that
you can go and wipe out children and
babies and they judge just the way they
justify that is by saying oh when these
kids grow up they're going to be
terrorists or whatever for that matter.
So in Islam we don't believe they're our
teachers. We are categorically told that
we are not allowed to harm innocent
people. Yes we have crazy Muslims we
have crazy Christians. We have crazy
secularists. ever crazy, you know,
crazy. Exactly. So, the thing is, uh,
it's about learning and educating
yourself. But, yeah, coming back to
like, for example, we talked about, you
know, you said high five. The reason why
it's my wife, it's not it's not that
you're not a Muslim. For example, that's
my friend. My wife is not allowed to
shake his hand. Okay? So, it's not a um
Muslim non-Muslim. It's a female male
issue. Why? Because let me tell you why.
Because at the end of the day, you know,
have you heard of the Me Too movement?
What's that? The Me Too movement. There
was this hashtagme too meaning woman
coming out about being sexually
harassed. So there'll be hashtag saying
me too. I went through that as well.
There was this big movement about a
couple of years ago and it it all stems
from like for example even in the
workplace sometimes in the workplace
they talking about what is comfortable.
For example when you're talking to your
female work colleague can you touch her
shoulder? Can you put your hand on her
knee? Can you uh touch her back? And
what we say is in Islam prevention is
better than cure. So we believe that the
opposite gender me towards a female or a
female towards a man vice versa. We have
we respect each other's space in the
sense where even you might think it's
just a handshake. We believe that uh the
way we are told that for example we keep
those barriers clean. Why? Because what
happens is things start off very slowly.
It can be a simple work colleague that
you know putting his hand on your
shoulder you might not feel comfortable.
So what Islam does isam says instead of
going into messy areas and it gets
really messy messages temptations
temptations. Yeah. So what Islam says is
let's deal prevention is better than
cure. Not let me drink one glass of uh
wine and then turn become an alcoholic
or like uh gambling like casino. It
destroys so many people's lives. So what
Islam does say is prevention is better
than cure. Don't even go there because
it's going to destroy your life and
that's what we see in the western world
so many men adopt addicted to
pornography alcohol gambling and this
destroys people's lives. You know I know
family members gambling destroy their
life. So what Islam does is it says in
every area be it intimate like sexual
gambling you protect yourself and you
have the protect the rights of others as
well. So we respect that because for for
someone they might say okay I don't mind
the handshake but I wouldn't prefer
someone touch him. So we say you know
why don't we just deal with it from the
getgo and say nobody touches no one and
we have a nice civilized dialogue and
then and the society as a whole will be
protected. So because that's one of the
aims of Islam is to protect the communal
rights. So we don't believe in an
individual saying I want to drink
alcohol. We say look you wanting to
drink alcohol could harm society. You
might be drunk drink driving and kill
three innocent people on the road.
That's why you're not allowed to drink
alcohol and nobody's and not only that
the biggest disease that the biggest
kill is heart disease, liver disease for
example. And it's all stem to alcohol.
So what it does is it harms your body.
It doesn't it harms your consciousness
because you do oh I was drunk. There's
no excuse. Oh I killed someone but I was
drunk. I'm so sorry my friend. There is
no excuse. So Islam has come to protect
us our our mind, our body, our soul, the
rights of others. So what Islam does is
it says listen we have these boundaries
to protect others and protect ourel
because when was talking about how you
you're dressed heartache is painful you
know if like if someone's been in a
relationship heart is quite painful so
what Islam is Islam says a woman should
be protected and a man's heart should be
protected so if a woman is dressed up in
a certain manner the man might want to
be with her for the wrong reasons he's
not in love with her he's there for one
thing personality is he you haven't
spoken to exactly exactly you know you
hear about like one night stand and
stuff like that it's like a total
stranger And you don't even know that
that person could be a killer. And not
only that, your daughter's 19 years old.
She can't defend herself as a grown man.
So Islam says, "No, we protect her in
that instance and say, "Hold on a
second, her father is a guardian." So if
I am interested, I have to speak to the
father cuz a man knows a man. Say, "Oh,
hold on a second, my friend. You're
going to have to deal with me if you
mistreat my daughter." So what Islam
does, Islam has these boundaries in
place and says her heart has to be
protected. Her father is a guardian. And
as a man, I'll be honest. If I'm going
to mess around with a girl, the last
person I want to speak to is her father.
Yeah. Exactly. or a brother. Yeah. Yeah.
Or a brother. You know, he's looking
strong. He's going to maybe beat he's
going to beat me up. What's your name?
Bailey. Bailey. Bailey. Nice meeting
you. Yeah, I can shake your hand. Your
mom's jealous now. So, so, so the the
the argument is that Islam has come for
us to have a relationship with God
Almighty. We believe he's one. We don't
believe he's a man or a woman. And we
believe that if we follow his guidance,
we will have um contentment and peace in
this life. And then in the hereafter, we
believe that we've come here for a
reason. We live, we have a purpose.
Because everything you can look around
you, what's your name? Lacy. Lacy. I'm
nice to meet Ali. So Lacy, everything
you look around you has a purpose. There
is not one thing you can show me on this
space that doesn't have a purpose. From
your earrings to your clothes to your
trainers to these books to this table,
everything has a purpose. You as a human
being are more complex. Your eye is more
complex in design. You're telling me
that everything has a purpose and
everything here has a designer, but you
have no designer. Of course you do. You
have a creator that created you and he
wants a relationship with you. And his
relationship with you is acknowledge
that I've created you. Your heart beats.
Do you tell your heart to beat? Hey,
listen. Don't stop beating. I I want to
wake up tomorrow. No. Your heart beats.
When you go sleep, do you tell yourself,
"Hey, don't stop breathing. I might
die." These are things that God Almighty
has created. You're a whole machine. You
know, and what God Almighty is saying is
have a relationship with me because he's
the one that provides for you. When you
drink water today, water didn't come out
of nowhere. Do you get it? The food that
you eat, the fact that the sun is a
perfect distance from our planet that we
can, you know, it's it was hot today.
I'm not going to lie. I came out I came
out to go for a jog. Yeah, bro. It was
30°. Uh yeah, it was it was really hot.
So the the the the sun is a perfect
distance that if it was any closer, we
will burn. If it was any further away,
we'll freeze. So those things, if you
think about it, the planet Earth is
actually serving us. So we say God
Almighty created us. And even like, you
know, I cut myself long time ago. What
tells my organisms in my body to say
he's bleeding. Blood clot, stop, heal.
Who's telling like I don't tell my like
I had a scar here. I think Can you still
see it? Yeah. Yeah. I had a scar here.
What tells my body and the white cells
in my body to say he's bleeding? We
never like a specific hormones released
in your body. It's like who's telling
these beings inside me that are
microscopic to help me survive. We
believe the one that created us and
we're saying let's have a relationship
with him. Like uh Bailey Bailey like
you're you're his mother. Yeah. He
should be grateful to you. He should be
respectful to you. This is another issue
that we have in the western world. This
hearing this. Yeah. Yeah. Bailey I'm I'm
on your case.
For to us in Islam, it's a major sin to
be disobedient to your mom and father.
Allah Allah in the Quran says don't even
say to your mom. Like you know when your
mom come says take the dinner. Oh mom.
Yeah. But these are things we try to
like do you get it? We all have that
shortcom. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? But Islam deals with the rights of
mother and father greatly. That's why
the prophet Muhammad a man came to he
asked him he said who has more rights my
mother or my father? He says your
mother. He says who next? He said then
your mother. He said who next? He said
then your mother. He said who next? He
said then your father. Why? Because we
acknowledge that you you looked after
him when he was in your womb. You gave
birth to him. Now imagine he grows up,
which he is a young man. How old are
you? 16.
Huh? Wow. You look I told you. So 13
years old. Imagine he grows up and says,
"Mom, you've done nothing for me. I'm
going to go and thank David over there."
Yeah. Yeah. It's that relationship. So
God Almighty says, "I'm the one that
sustains and looks after you." Have that
relationship. Be gratitude. Be grateful
to me. You know, you've done everything
for him. The last thing you want for him
is to turn his back on you and and say,
"I don't know you." So, we just need to
have that relationship. But anyways,
yeah, I don't want to go on a lecture,
but if there's any questions you have, I
I'm I'm here. Yeah, we're here every
Friday, Sunday. If you have any
questions for me, yeah, you can come.
You ask my questions. If you want to
carry on, I can carry on. It's totally
up to you. Yeah. Oh, I love it. I do. I
love it. And I had a very good chat with
your colleague. I want to say thank you.
Yeah. Sam, I just want to say thank you
to you. Thank you.
Yes. And thank you. Thank you for
talking to us and not being ignorant
like that man. A little bit. Yeah, it
was it was it was it was you handed me.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
Integrity.
He had none. Yes. Yes. Thank you. I
appreciate it. Bailey, call to your mom.
Yes. Okay. Don't forget if he if he
doesn't behave, come here. Yeah. Thank
you. Thank you.